the clark county school district is
working to improve the air quality in
school buildings
not only just upgrading the air filters
but also installing new purification
systems
aimed at stopping the transmission of
cobit 19. 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us the enhancements
a focus on health we're going to take
every precaution to protect the safety
of not only our kids but also our staff
superintendent dr jesus jarrah visits
roundy elementary school
he steps inside to see how a recently
installed air purification system
is enhancing the building we're looking
at the operational dollars that we've
had in place
you know to really make sure that this
is a priority this reduces
ultra fine particulate the district is
spending roughly 1.7 million dollars to
place
this unit in 850 ccsd rooms
primarily health offices and designated
isolation rooms
for anyone showing coveted symptoms
we're actively installing the systems
now and
plan to have them all installed before
students return to school
needlepoint bipolar ionization
technology this is how it works
the system puts ions into the airstream
when dispersed in a room the ions
combined with floating particles
including the covet 19 virus positive
and negative ions touch the surface
protein of the virus
it renders them inactive along with
installing the air purification system
the district is also continuing a
long-term project of replacing
carpets in the schools this is the
biggest air filter you have in a space
so we've replaced carpet in over 100
schools in the last 12 months
other recent school enhancements include
upgrading air filters
and cleaning the air conditioner coils
we are taking active measures
to improve facilities when all students
and staff come back
kristen drummond 8 news now so the
district plans to look at the cares act
dollars to reimburse the cost of those
air purification systems
ccsd cannot afford to install it in
every room because it was cost
about 38 million dollars